oh okay just like the last game it's a
queen's pawn opening and how will magnus
react
in this tournament we've already seen
him play the dutch defense the king's
indian defense the grunfeld defense
every opening and uh now okay it's a
queen scan bit
maybe the netflix show inspiring the two
players will we see the queen's gambit
accepted which means black capturing
this white pawn that's just moved taking
the gambited pawn but no the gambit is
declined and magnus goes for the slav
laughing meanwhile
this time not laughing about falling
asleep laughing about something else
clearly but this is known as one of the
most solid openings in chess black just
puts pawns on light squares blocks
things up and uh tries to stay solid so
okay right now dude has got to decide
whether to trade pawns in the center
bring his knight out push your pawn
this is uh a line i think we call the
slow slav
just because things will take a while to
open up later yeah i was just about to
say this i i haven't seen him playing
the real slav i think usually he goes
for the
yeah it's it's a clever move order that
has actually been advocated by um sam
shankland in his chessable course i'm
not quite sure it's a slow slav but uh
um
anyway the whole point is that you don't
have to deal with pawn takes porn and
just a nice kind of move order trick
and magnus actually choosing
the queen developing the queen which is
a solid and white is just going for a
slightly better position yep dude
developing the green land magnus
reacting by pushing upon he's getting
ready to develop black's light squared
bishop which is actually the problem
child in this type of opening look at
the black light squad bishop it's
actually blocked in by its own knight
previously by a pawn so now it's created
uh it has a nice home at least on the b7
square then black's root can slide
across to the uh to the center and
i think both sides will focus on
castling the king in a few moves time
the center is closed right now so
there's no urgency
for that both sides just developing
pieces maybe aiming for pawn breaks
later meanwhile duda he's staring up
into the heavens looking up into the sky
beth harmon yeah he's just trying to
remember
yeah exactly which which line to test
exactly so but it's it's gonna be like
that you know they're gonna castle and
and develop and and um
some rooks to the to the same file as
the queen pointing at the queen you know
you have seen this game before you've
probably even played it i've played
something very similar you need to
the white queen and there's just a bit
of a standoff yeah
and uh white star square bishop will
find itself on the edge of the board on
the b2 square
and uh we did this is like the perfect
opportunity to ask you both a question
that has been put to you by johnny slaw
who asks
david
if you were to play magnus in a blitz
game as white what would your opening
choice be
oh good question um i have played magnus
a few times
normally informal blitz games just
friendly blitz games
and uh
i've tried two different strategies one
is the reti opening just kind of solidly
getting out surviving the opening and
trying to take the game quickly uh
towards the middle game but um i've had
slightly more success maybe by opening
with the king's pawn and being very
direct something like the scotch game
but the problem is against magnus no
matter what opening you choose at some
point he tends to outplay you so um yeah
it's it's a tricky one i think that's
the hardest uh
hardest
kind of match up in chess playing magnus
and blitz how about you punters uh i
will definitely go with the king spawn
you know um why because
no because the best chance for me is to
attack him hmm
or that he falls asleep like
you see there it is again is it sleep or
is it live
you're like a hypnotist dentist every
time you say the word sleep magnus just
his head goes down yeah no no but i
would definitely go for an attack you
know because that's the best chance to
win
even from the get-go
yeah
you have to you have to trash yeah
because it's also
you have to also go on your own strong
points yeah
because what a lot of players do as a
mistake is that they try to just
you know oh i'm playing magnus i
remember prague was playing
one time and he
fell into thoughts after like three
moves you know and then they fought like
for one hour
and that's his respect or something like
this that he's thinking you know he
doesn't really think about most
disrespectful and then after you know 15
20 minutes oh i can't play that i can't
play that uh
yeah so you have to believe in your play
you know and attack him and usually the
guys who are
having the best scores are actually
those guys that are not afraid of him
yeah incidentally i've been this morning
i was watching the course that i was
talking about yesterday by
for for chess 24 premium members uh it's
one by spanish grammar
even salgardo lopez
schwindler no this was the one that uh
he talks about he talks about um playing
like magnus and rapid and blitz but he
has a chapter on how to beat magnus how
to play against him and uh there he he
says more or less like you guys that
you should play the best moves which is
easier said than done but you should
actually aim for positional advantages
because uh this is something that magnus
is so good at that he will himself feel
discomfort
yeah i think maybe in a classical game
that would be the way to go because
direct attacks might not work so much
but in blitz yeah yeah at least i think
you have to attack your attacker yeah
because
he's better in those
because blitz has a lot of intuition
you know and his intuition is the best
in the world so
because if you go with a slow positional
game
what i've noticed at least is that for
example if i play with blitz game with
informal rescue zombie minus or
that his intuition is much better than
mine
so if i play in his way
he's going to spot the moves faster than
me yeah and that's a problem for me
because the blitz is about time as well
you know right so then let's say that i
survive but then i have no times i lose
so now i'm going to lose some time
so it's always
so so i can't play the same type of
chess as fast as he can do it even if i
find all those moves
i will lose some time
yeah that's good advice for any player
playing against someone a bit stronger
than them just don't give them positions
where they can rely purely on their
intuition just make them calculate make
them find only moves or make them kind
of make big decisions where they have
three or four options on every turn
that's the only way to confuse them and
showing no fear
often when i play low-rated players they
show me too much respect and then i know
that eventually i'll beat them just
because they're kind of submitting to
everything i want to do on the board but
uh if they just go all out at me just no
fear going for my king sacrificing
pieces
i get afraid and even magnus does that
even against lower rated players
occasionally uh we've seen it from
daniel dubov attacking magnus he's
checkmated him a few times uh we've seen
magnus lose a few games on the tour just
when people stop respecting him too much
and meanwhile a few developments on this
board we did see actually a trade of
pawns in the center so we were talking
about how it was a bit of a standoff
things would just slowly open up but
things open up very quickly due to going
on the attack
or trying at least against magnus and
suddenly the white queen has found
herself over on the side of the board
the black queen now developing and this
is really interesting for magnus he's
kind of keeping us guessing he's keeping
dude guessing which way is the black
king gonna go and that's the main
question right now black has a healthy
position in general the two black
bishops pointing towards the white king
but if the black king goes over towards
the white queen whoops you're going to
walk into an attack if you go over to
the other side it's maybe more open but
at least white has no pieces over on the
left flank so
really
kind of fascinating moment i'm expecting
duda to think for quite a long time on
the next two or three moves
just because he's going to be making a
plan for if magnus castle's kingside on
the right side and uh also if magnus
castle's on the opposite flank
yeah it's going to
sharp is also a lot of interesting
yeah
get
variations so they are thinking about
they have to calculate now
because the natural move will be to to
move
the pawn next to the bishop one one
square
and then try to develop the bishop
so you because you need to develop your
pieces you want to get that one out
uh but then there is also some
interesting ideas you know maybe you can
go completely
crazy with yeah magnus is always going
to try to to somehow sacrifice his his
g-pawn so this one is kind of because if
that pawn is gone
you have a lot of pressure down towards
uh doula's king yeah so that's what he's
looking for ways to do this move
basically yeah so something like this
later just give up a pawn and try to
attack the white king using some open
lines and i think that's the big
question and uh okay dude didn't develop
his bishop using this diagonal instead
he just planted it in the center uh just
a bit of a
kind of stop gap move looks a bit i'm
surprised i'm surprised by that move i
actually was calculating what's going to
happen after pawn takes pawn which is
like a very forcing move
and
then you know black has some questions
to answer
where are you gonna are you gonna
capture with the queen
probably you're gonna have to and then
you know the queen can get kicked around
yeah for example queen takes born now
white can play the same move he did in
the game but just gaining time against
the black queen forcing her back um so
interesting decision it's funny you guys
were saying okay push this pawn or maybe
capture this pawn i was looking the
other direction i was thinking maybe
bring the push back here
my other first thought was maybe bring
the brush about here
just to destabilize this pawn and if the
bishop is captured then the white queen
can actually capture the knight
attacking this rook and stopping back
from castle and cutting across this
diagonal
so castling would be illegal here but uh
so many tempting options dude i chose
maybe
i wouldn't say the least ambitious of
them but uh at least the least direct of
all those options white bishop now on a
decent square and it's that question for
magnus do you castle this way uh and
maybe walk into an attack because the
white queen is over on this side or do
you be even more ambitious and castle on
the opposite flank but this is also
risky because suddenly white is going to
be the one throwing pawns forward
towards your king later and with
opposite side castling it's just a race
whose attack is going to be quickest
white can start that attack at some
point by throwing pawns forward black as
well as pontius mentioned will start
attacks by throwing his pawns forward
even at the cost of pawns just to open
up lines and uh i personally want to see
magnus do this just because it'll be so
exciting for us
sat here in the studio but
for him he needs to weigh up the uh the
risk entails and uh it's not really a
magnus type of move to do that right
to initiate kind of real chaos it would
be more maybe magnus's style to just uh
after this bishop moved to i don't know
just kind of
stabilize the position it's just not
easy
to find how to do that
he would love to just trade things off
and make it clear
make the path to a plan clear but
how that's the big question black's king
has to commit itself sooner or later
yeah that's not an easy decision uh
david and uh whilst we come up with a
solution
um i wanted to show you a very cool
selfie and i love it when everyone tells
us where they're watching the show from
and saif shikhli is watching the games
from an iraq oil field
and yeah there he is in his uniform and
incredible staff saif so thank you for
sharing how you're watching and if you
two want to send us your questions your
thoughts your selfies remember take them
in landscape mode then as always you can
tweet us using the hashtag
and i would also like to ask you to a
question that jane asks us
she says i will be playing my first ever
over-the-board tournament at my
university any tips or things i should
keep an eye on
so i'm assuming that uh jane's
experience has mostly been
uh
i guess
um
first thing i would say
i mean writing down the moves can be
tricky something to get used to
keep an eye on that clock
you have to press it rather than just uh
automatic like uh like we see in online
chat yeah i would i would say after
every move if you have the time i would
try and do a quick scan of the board and
blunder check just make sure that
nothing is going to attack it and i just
ask yourself you know
is this trade good is what i'm making
good and
think about what your opponent wants to
do and if you can stop it
now just visually it looks different
right a physical board compared to the
online screen so definitely double check
things big difference you know 2d and 3d
so this is this is the thing that she
needs to before the tournament she
should play also some game with some
friend or something yes to get used to
the difference because one of the
biggest difference there is david said
with time
that you basically
online you can make quite a lot of moves
in no time you can even use this
pre-move function so you can make like
10 moves in a in a second
and when you play live you can really
not do that so the time is actually a
factor and this is something
that if you have played online a lot uh
this is going to be a shock when you get
to a real tournament and one other thing
i just thought about when you're playing
online chess you can kind of hover your
mouse over every single piece you can
even click on it and maybe try to make a
move and over-the-board chess you cannot
do that
if you touch a piece you have to move it
exactly so uh always good good idea too
so you can't change your move no which
you can do online you know you can hover
over a piece and then you change to
another one yeah i had a moment you know
because i haven't played over the board
chess for quite a while so i had a
moment when i was where assad was
practicing his chess skills against me
and i wanted to take i picked up my
queen and i wanted to take it back but i
was like no i can't do that there's no
it's not the etiquette anymore so i just
put it down i just thought okay i have
to stick to my move even if it's a
blunder all right start cheating against
the kids
yeah no i i don't know i didn't cheat i
didn't cheat i picked up my queen and i
was thinking this is not a good piece to
move
[Laughter]
i did once try to take back in a symbol
and they went no i always allow take
backs but they the kids
they don't allow me that privilege i
thought okay fair enough fair enough
well talking about kids and online chess
we were talking about um chess to change
contests coming up on april 23rd right
um we talked about it during the first
game it's it's basically teaming up
business people maybe in silicon valley
uh with kids and chess talents basically
from africa to play online tournament
hand and brain super cool concept
and you told me there's actually spots
available yeah yeah definitely so if
someone sees this program or has some
friend who you know from the business
community or it it can also be you know
athletes or someone else you know that
or yes
hobby players that are interested in
taking part you know then they can just
reach out to us they can always enter
the website you know businessmen
kids.com it's not
that complicated so
then they can read more about it and
they can just send us an inquiry
because we still have spots left yeah so
if someone wants to play they can
they can come all right so uh we
actually we have some information about
this in the bottom of the screen you can
see right now i'll add into that
how
businesses now can reach out if they
want to join this fantastic event
so i'll
guide them to the website where they can
find information about signing up for
playing this online hand and brain
tournament with
chess talents from africa
very very cool initiative all right we
do have some moves on the board we do
have a couple of moves so uh actually
magnus just pushed upon so still
delaying that big decision with the
black king which he might have to make
on this turn but uh after black just
pushed upon we saw a capture in the
center one that ivanka was advocating
and now after a trade of one set of
pawns white's knight has just planted
itself in the middle of the board and
this is a multi-purpose move the white
knight if given the opportunity might
dart over to the left start attacking
the black queen
that could be very scary for magnus to
deal with and uh meanwhile still this
big decision which side to go with the
king and
suddenly it's it's not so clear the big
question is whether you can even castle
on this turn without allowing some nasty
uh nasty side effects nasty kind of
consequences so
right now if we jump in the big question
is can you castle and okay magnus delays
it again i was going to say if you
castle on this side the queen side then
this king is a big target white tonight
he's gonna jump over attack your queen
attack this pawn as well this looks
disastrous for black so uh this was not
possible but if you castled the other
way and suddenly there are consequences
such as bishop takes pawn i highlighted
this concept this kind of pattern a few
moves ago again this pawn is overworked
suddenly
if it captures the white bishop then the
black knight falls and suddenly whoops
this king is just too open uh we could
see what we call a rook lift a rook
swing just check and uh this would be
disaster again for the black king so
magnus decided okay still delaying uh
castling and pushing upon taking this
square away from the white knight
just covering it but it's so slow and
duda okay i was going to say there might
be consequences there might be threats
but he just reacts by pushing a pawn
getting ready to
push even more and gain even more space
and still that dilemma exists for magnus
how is he going to get his king to
safety neither side looks safe and the
longer you leave it here the more risk
you entail so
i'm not envious here of magnus at all i
think it's not his type of position he's
going to get attacked no matter what and
as ponte said that's a decent strategy
against the best players in the world
just attack them fearless fearlessly and
even they do get nervous sometimes yeah
um one of the things i kind of wanted to
say though is that duder's last move
seems to me and i know it is actually
threatening to push the pawn forward and
attack the bishop chase it away but it
does feel like it's a little bit slow
and it doesn't quite feel like
this is the most critical continuation
that magnus should be scared about i
mean i just with the king in the middle
of the board you're kind of i was kind
of hoping for something very very
aggressive
and uh just in light of dude's
continuation i mean can the black bishop
just step back with two squares and just
go i know it's on a dance but it is
gonna look at the black the white queen
and uh defend the knight and get ready
to kind of castle the king
i think you have to play a move like
that right now magnus has to go on the
defensive start uh kind of taking these
measures to uh
first of all castle his own king but
prevent white's activity coming
yeah jovanka it's interesting you say
that that move is slow
that was my first instinct to i felt
like white maybe could have thought
a bit longer gone for something a bit
more direct but then again we did see
magnus slightly shake his head and uh he
is still the one if any of the two
players he is the one magnus here who is
nervous already who's
who needs to play accurately needs to
play on the defensive i think one wrong
move here as black and you might even
lose oh wow and for white you've got a
bit more margin for error uh still some
hope for black if uh the black king
could find safety but
it's not a given right now i like
ivanka's move though bringing the black
light black dark square bishop sorry
back planting it in front of the black
king just to act as a defender
just to keep the position stable for the
next few moves it seems like magnus is
making some sort of a plan mr herbert
from ireland donated
and two dollars thank you so much and uh
please if you do have the opportunity uh
please donate to our fundraiser for
unicef doing life-saving work for the
refugees now from the war in ukraine and
also people and children still living
inside ukraine david from united kingdom
donated doctor david is that what it
says wow cool
that's your nickname
dr david that's why we have to call
david no we're not on the show i wish i
had that title
yeah thank you so much everyone for uh
participating in this important
fundraiser and uh after this game we're
gonna have another charity challenge
it's actually gonna be with 15 year old
sod who is a big chess talent 2 000
on the rating list in classical chess
and you know
uh pontus he's actually from the
business meets chess and kids program
basically what is his story
well uh his story is uh basically that
he has parents from somalia
and uh they of course immigrated to to
norway
um so
yeah there is always i actually always
but there is a lot of times there is
some challenges when you call it a new
country and so on you know when they try
to establish and to get integrated to
get to know you know
local people norwegian people and so on
so sad for example he has
he picked up chess at some point and he
started to play and there was his chess
club baron has helped him a lot
throughout the years as well that's
great and then
we came in contact with him and he's
also his brothers uh
abdi shakur and the resect they also
play oh cool and they they're also quite
good yeah uh
so we just fought to a school and that
that's such a kids that they are
interested in chess and todd is the most
interested in chess you know so he's
also the best uh right moment super
talented yeah and he's playing in the
norwegian
natural youth team
so
he you know he's very very interesting
he asks questions about chess all the
time and he was playing with juanki in
the break and wow he really really likes
chess you know
and then
but the problem is of course the
founding and this kind of things for him
to go to a tournament you know
and and
as well like other sports it's expensive
right expensive to to to buy books you
know to buy equipment to
to maybe if he is going to watch some
chess able course or whatever it is you
know
everything costs money you know and
for example to study uh when he's going
now to this uh entity elite sports yep
gymnasium which also magnus went to the
moment went there exactly you know then
you know there is school fees
and that's very hard for the family to
pay oh because they don't have that
wallet and and therefore uh you know it
helps a lot if he
you know can meet some some business guy
and and like with morton now with
ferdinand you know they found each other
and then third certainly sponsors it
so
this is how you can use chess you know
to match people and now we i mean i've
been watching him play today uh before
the show he has a future in chess there
is no doubt about it it's a great story
and oh i'm looking forward to seeing him
play in the how many moves do you think
he can last against minus 10 with two
minutes on the clock
well uh
you can turn it around how many moves
can the magnus app
because i think it's he's the favorite
yeah he's better than that yeah if he
had unlimited time he would definitely
uh be able to win that game but he's
quite fast actually so he's uh he's 2600
something on chess.com so he's he's
incredible he's he's better in faster
games yeah he likes it also he likes the
when there's some tension
he's going to be our youngest
participant ever in the charity
challenge uh yongsan and that's coming
after this game i bet his idol is uh
magnus carlsen and uh is he fighting to
survive in this game magnus now still i
would say yes if you look at all of
white's pieces they're mobilized okay uh
really interesting castling now with
black all of white's piece immobilized
two white rooks teaming up
the white bishops in the uh in the
middle of the board kind of with that
gays focus on both sides the white queen
nicely placed through an attack white
centralized knight they're all fantastic
i was about to say magnus his king
situation was still uh not ideal but he
has decided to castle and i think he's
banking on some tricks here he
definitely is because my first instinct
was like wow he's allowing that trick
that david pointed out bishop takes pawn
and
suddenly the knight on f6 is a little
bit unstable because pawn takes bishop
isn't really possible because the queen
takes knight and the king is just too
shaky so i mean magnus has a crafty
trick up his sleeve though his idea is
actually not to capture the bishop but
instead okay bishop takes porn himself
quite possibly yeah bishop takes pawn
would be a check and after the white
queen recaptures then after we see a
trade here we could see black
recapturing the white bishop here i
still prefer white to be honest because
black has an isolated pawn white has a
potential past pawn over here as well
but uh maybe this is what magnus is
relying on and maybe also another trick
in this position if white had gone for
this then possibly now he could have
captured the pawn and when the white
king moves he could have either put his
queen in the middle offering a queen
trade or brought his bishop back and
it's very complicated i think duda just
didn't want to allow this an attack
against the queen attack against the
knight therefore he dropped his knight
back and uh in this position after
white's knight is retreated there's one
clear idea dude wants to break open the
line towards the black queen push this
pawn forward this is supported by nearly
all of white's pieces right now and
magnus reacted very quickly by bringing
his bishop to the center it's something
we saw duda do actually in the first
game planting the bishop in the middle
of the board and now just trying to
trade off pieces before it's too late
note how as well this bishop defending
the black knight so that trick we
highlighted
of the white bishop taking upon is no
longer on the cards black's pieces all
defending each other and uh what do we
think
magnus just about in time to protect
everything it feels like he was really
playing with fire with his king but now
he's castled now he's at least ready if
needed to trade some pieces
i think magnus is okay again well he's
up uh a bit on time as well yeah
so
but also i think
magnus is a really good defender yeah
he i've seen him play this
bullet and blitz or whatever it is
against naka and i was
i'm rarely
extremely impressed by by something but
those games are very impressive because
they play on only one minute and and and
this is seconds you know and the fan he
defends so well quality is there yeah
the quality is very high and also many
times he defends so well
then usually naka is the one who's
losing the games because he gets angry
and frustrated and then he has the
blunder something and mangas wins and
because magnus has sometimes you know 20
moves he needs to play the only move and
he doesn't it's incredible i remember
there was also something with chess.com
because they have this cheating sensor
and it actually was screaming my first
time minus was playing in a computer
cheater because he hit two high
percentage yeah one of the moves of the
computer the first movement yeah we
let's jump into the position because
dude is thinking a long time and he's
under four minutes right now and uh he
has a huge decision to make because he
has to do something he has to go on the
attack i think it's time either to push
this pawn forward as he was planning to
do or maybe even just come back with his
knight to the center because what else
suddenly you don't want to trade off the
rooks if all the rooks disappear for
example if white initiates these trades
then black is actually going to have the
better pieces black's queen now is gonna
firstly maybe start threatening some
checkmating ideas maybe the black queen
as well can jump to the center attacking
white's bishop note how the white queen
is suddenly offside not helping and
white would be in huge trouble and we're
actually seeing something very similar
to this i mentioned the knight may be
coming back to plug the open file to
stop any exchanges of the rooks instead
white pushed forward and magnus
instantly trying to put pressure now on
dude on the clock traded a set of rooks
and uh if duda recaptures then magnus
will do the same he will just offer this
trade of rooks trying to break through
towards this white king we talk about it
all the time the white king lacking
breathing space lacking lift lacking an
escape square and
back rank tactics against this king
might continue we could see a line just
to show one variation maybe for example
if white captures a pawn gets greedy
then we would see a trade of rooks and
black's queen now just breaking through
the white queen not able to help out so
we saw another move there from duda and
a bit of a weird one a bit of an ugly
move
not capturing with all of the rooks but
instead in this position sorry uh taking
it back with his bishop and the reason i
say ugly is because this bishop on the
first rank
could be a target to blackrook sliding
across and look at this there's a
massive trap in the position
if white plays the most greedy move and
plays pawn takes pawn it looks like
white's winning a pawn attacking the
black queen with a pawn attacking with a
rook as well then suddenly
magnus would win with a queen sacrifice
queen takes rook eliminating the only
defender of white's bishop and after the
queen is recaptured this is the exact
tactical tactic i was talking about this
is checkmate background checkmate no
escape square for the white king and uh
this is actually on the cards right now
dude duda doesn't fall into that trap
the bishop was a target pawn takes pawn
would have lost on the spot as we just
saw so he brings his bishop back to a
square it cannot be targeted but things
are turning in magnus's favor this white
queen now just offside and uh i expect
magnus here maybe it's just to block
things up and uh the game goes on but
white is playing temporarily without the
queen and okay he does this he blocks
things up and he's the only one with
control over the open file now the bar
is liking it for the world champion
right now yeah and uh
duda you know many people will be asking
what's happening here because uh he just
pushed forward his protective passport
and the most amazing pawn there is and
what happens here and he's just
offered it up for grabs
i think magnus
actually kind of trusted dude's bluff on
the last turn due to push to pawn
forward attacking black's bishop i think
that pawn could have been captured
safely and
that's just due to some back rank tricks
um actually very similar to the ones i
highlighted so duda gave up a pawn i
think
magnus could have just grabbed it but
magnus said no i trust you and now look
at that black bishop in the corner
it talked about bad pieces white's queen
being a bit offside but suddenly that
black bishop
it's just a dead piece it's a block of
wood and dude is shaking his head
but he's doing okay he can just support
this white pawn he can protect it and
the game goes on black playing without
this bishop in the corner yeah i mean he
has a knight that is a willing defender
a light square bishop that is willing to
come to its aid and uh duda does put his
knight on the edge of the board with the
sole purpose of locking that light
squared bishop out and
i
like this position suddenly for duda
i mean but the one thing i the one thing
is i mean how stable is that pawn in
reality
can the can black start to go well no
big deal play around it
yeah so this white pawn this very far
advanced white pawn currently is tying
down the black queen it's caging this
black bishop in the corner as we
mentioned uh but yeah magnus is going to
hope that it can be easily blockaded you
can just ignore it pretend it's not
there
the black knight jumping into the center
and actually maybe it's more important
that the white queen is just not
coordinated with the rest of our army
and after this bishop move it would be
super tempting now if i were magnus to
use the black knight capture white's
dark square bishop and suddenly white is
fun there we go we saw that trade very
quickly there from magnus and suddenly
the black queen can start threatening
this isolated white pawn in the center
of the board the one that has just
recaptured suddenly white's really weak
on the dark squares the brook jumps in
instead attacking two pawns now
and
i mentioned things were turning in
duda's favor but now that black has
complete grip on the dart squares
i think it's actually the other way
around due to shaking his head as well
and lower on the clock definitely
yeah suddenly i mean this is still very
tense it could go either way but
suddenly maybe magnus is the happier of
the two
and uh the white knight i mean which
piece is worse here guys the white
knight on the edge of the wood or that
black bishop in the corner it's not
clear actually maybe they just balance
each other out
yeah maybe what's needed is uh
maybe for white just to kind of roll the
dice and
try to bring the queen into the game
even at the cost of some extra material
and that just bank on the fact that this
past pawn needs to be pushed can find a
way to kind of try to dis dislodge the
black queen yeah the only problem not
easy though yeah white's queen now she
is kind of tied down to the h2 pawn the
the whites pawn on the h2 square if you
look at black's bishop in the center and
the black queen they're eyeing up this
pawn on the diagonal so white's queen
temporarily tied down dude looks really
unhappy meanwhile just psychologically i
think he's uh just struggling to adapt
to this kind of transition of black
suddenly getting active uh with his rook
and
pontus does it
look to you that white's lost control
yeah i think it's totally lost control
yeah well i've totally lost control yeah
yeah because he also lost control over
the clock
so i think 30 seconds yeah yeah
he's his his inner
big problems
he just looks uncomfortable i mean
visibly
and dude normally he keeps a poker face
if he can i've seen him having dead lost
position sometimes the computer says
plus five for the opponent but he still
looks super calm this time no he's
shaking his head and okay he brings his
bishop oh no there we go i mean it's
just expected because of the clock
because he's lost control on the
position and that's when blunders
happened they don't just occur out of
nothing
most of the time and okay here we see
stockfish the computer suggestions the
top two moves which give black a
significant advantage they're also the
most obvious moves in the position
sometimes that's not the case but here
black has a choice the black rook in the
center is attacked by white's bishop you
can just sidestep and capture a pawn
magnus does this you could have captured
the other pawn as well on the left side
that would have been strong too but uh
yeah it's looking very good for magnus
right now he's a pawn up and white's
struggling to create counter threats
any compensation here
okay the white bishop stepped back that
is a bad sign for duda
and okay magnus now
can he continue being greedy
if the black rook goes away from the
center though maybe white's queen can
recentralize itself
he's relying on tricks to save this game
magnus is a pawn up and magnus is
completely dominant on the dark squares
do you think definitely a young crystal
will lose this
with also 30 seconds on the clock
it's looking likely but i mean the win
isn't a clear cut right i mean
magnus still has to work uh well put
some put in some effort and try and find
it it all depends on why it's far
advanced pawn actually if it can ever
kind of if you can ever dislodge the
black queen and push that pawn you might
even win with white but
uh for now that white pawn is under
locking key and
yeah i mean just okay magnus does get
greedy as i mentioned and now two pawns
up for black
how do you break through in the dark
squares that's a problem okay uh white
side steps with this rook huge threat in
the position white i mentioned the
background checkmates against the white
king now blacks king is the one
threatened white's rook wants to step up
to the top of the board and that would
actually end in checkmate because
white's bishop covers the only escape
square for the black king
magnus can deal with this right he can
step back with his bishop for example
the dark square bishop block the white
queen's diagonal yeah and unfortunately
that was uh logical and very good
and now the queen i guess has to
maybe threaten something maybe move the
queen to the edge of the um not to the
mid edge of the board to the middle of
the board and at least threaten the
check
yeah the white queen as mentioned needs
to centralize herself there we go that
was actually a huge threat as you have
mentioned the white queen and bishop
lined up on the same diagonal trying to
sneak through to the black king that's
just been blocked
by magnus's last pawn push suddenly
black's king is super safe and now here
i suggest uh when in doubt
push harry
and the thing is that i kind of want to
activate the rook but that's not really
possible but if you go into the corner
the issue still remains that the white
king is potentially unsafe can be
vulnerable to a rook coming down to the
first row and that would be something
that is called the back rank mate
um difficult
difficult job now yeah and there was
also one trick in the position white
rook wanted to come up to the seventh
rank on the last go but it would have
just been captured and uh yeah this one
looking very one-sided traffic right now
magnus all he needs to do bring the
black brook into the game back and
i can't even see a move for white at
this point oh you'll stop on the c file
and then it's over yeah you're right
punches just and then it's gonna step up
with the king or something quite soon um
yes that's i think this is uh
it's not very good for for duda there's
still some kind of tricks you know maybe
there's the possibility of white playing
bishop takes pawn so i like your move of
just going
stepping up with the king that's a very
magnus move uh stepping forward with the
black king just covering everything
defending everything but instead magnus
grabs another pawn he's actually three
pawns up and
we've just seen dude of resign i think
we have magnus takes the win wow
with the white pieces and